hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
in book three of his poem on the nature
of things lucretius is not only going to
present his own
epicurean doctrines on the nature of the
mind or spirit and its relation to the
body he's also going to
criticize a number of what he considers
to be erroneous
that many people including other
philosophers even other philosophers
that the epicureans draw upon like
democritus
have fallen into when it comes to
understanding
the relationship between the the mind
and spirit and the
body and the first one that he talks
about is actually quite interesting
he tells us that
some people think that the sentience of
the mind is not lodged in any particular
part of the body but is a vital
condition of the body what the greeks
call
a
harmony
of we could say the elements of the body
or the parts of the body so
this is an idea that goes very far back
we see plato having socrates combat this
idea in his dialogues so there
presumably were a lot of people
not just in plato's time and not just in
the time of epicurus and in the time of
lucretius
who are holding this position but
throughout time there's a lot of people
who want to say that the mind is
ultimately what we could call an epi
phenomenon of the body the body's doing
certain things and that makes the mind
the way
that it is and we see a lot of people
saying things like that with with the
brain these days and
lucretius is going to say that's
actually not going to work and the
argument that he gives for this is kind
of interesting because it does seem to
be in a little bit of tension with some
of the other arguments that he's going
to give in the next you know few pages
uh or hundreds of lines so he points out
that the body
or the mind can be doing badly and he's
the example of illness
while the other one
isn't
so he says the visible body is obviously
ill well in some other unseen part we
are enjoying ourselves so if the
what's going on with the mind or the
spirit is just a reflection of the
harmony or in this case disharmony of
the bodily parts if the body's not doing
good the mind ought to not be doing good
as well and he says that
no less often the reverse happens one
who is sick at heart
enjoys
bodily well being so somebody might be
upset over
the loss of a job or a breakup or the
death of you know a family member or
something like that physically they're
they're just fine their body's in
perfect harmony with itself
in terms of the mind or the spirit
they're unhappy right so this uh he says
should disabuse us of the idea
that the mind is merely
a harmony of the body he actually goes
on
as well and says consider what happens
when we surrender our limbs to soothing
slumber and our body lies insensible
at the very same time there's something
else in us that's awake
to all kinds of stimuli something that
gives free admittance to the motions of
joys and heartaches void of substance
what is he talking about having dreams
right you can dream and your body's just
laying there doing nothing
it's not a harmony of the body that's
producing it's a mind zone activity
and so he goes on and he says that
um let's drop this name harmony passed
on
passed down to the musicians from the
heights of helicon or else perhaps they
fetched it themselves from some other
source and applied it to the matter of
their art which had that no name of its
own and so he's attributing this to the
musical people right and so he's gotten
rid of this idea
the next thing that he has to discuss
and he's trying to affirm this point of
view the mind or the spirit
both together and the body are
material and they're material
really in the same kind of way they're
made of atoms of course the mind slash
spirit the atoms composing that are much
finer
and
you know they move around they're much
more mobile right but they're ultimately
you know made of atoms just like the
body is
and here he says something that like i
said can be in a little bit of tension
with what he the argument he made
against the first idea
so
not only
can the mind and body be doing different
things
they're also closely connected together
so he says the mind actually shares in
the the body's experiences
and it sympathizes as one way of
translating it consentire it literally
senses or feels with
the body so you see where the tension
lies you know they're distinct from each
other in what they're experiencing but
they also do affect each other
very
closely and the argument here is well
unless they were both material
that really wouldn't be possible so if
the mind and spirit was something
totally different some sort of you know
spiritual substance non-bodily you
couldn't actually get that interaction
going in the first place so uh you know
are these possible to hold at the same
time i would say yes it's just picking
out different kinds of
situations
the third thing that he talks about
and there's a couple things that are you
know figuring into this so we should
think of this as a class of
of
positions that are being
attacked and defended
he tells us that neither the body nor
the mind on its own
possesses sensation
so this is a very interesting idea right
for lucretius
the mind and the body are not related to
use you know descartes
metaphor like the pilot in the ship
right
instead the mind and the body are
essentially the mind is interfused
within the body
and it's because of that that we can
actually have
sensations and so he's going to give two
main arguments here he's also going to
you know criticize a little bit later on
people who think that like after we die
the body you know goes down to the
underworld and we see and hear and smell
things he says that that's not the case
you don't you don't have that capacity
like some ghost to see things without
without eyeballs right you have to have
the bodily organs and he says you know
we do experience
bodily sensations
we
um
see you know through and we feel you
could say through the body itself
and
that is um you know quite
important you know there's sort of he
talks about a communal
life right between the spirit and the
body so he says it's clear neither body
nor mind by itself without the other
aids possesses the power of sensation
it's by the interacting motions of the
two that the flame of sentience is
kindled in our flesh and he also talks
about this is like you know having uh
growth within us both the mind and the
body are
growing as well
so he says
if anyone denies the body is sentient
and believes it's the spirit
interfused throughout the body that
assumes this motion we term sensation
he's fighting against manifest facts
open facts right who can explain what
bodily sensation really is
if not
if it be not such as is palpably
presented to us by experience you want
to know what pain is like poke yourself
or you know
pinch yourself or something like that
you want to know what it is to look
around at things well look around at
things with your eyeballs right
on the other side though he says that
the body it's not like the body is
this machine that's getting the things
and then passing the signals
on to
the mind which is a totally separate
thing no the the body's organs he says
are sort of like windows
he says it's impossible to maintain the
eyes can see nothing but the mind peeps
out through them as though through open
doors the sense of sight itself leads
the other way dr dragging and tugging us
right to the eyeballs
right
often for instance we cannot see bright
objects because our eyes are dazzled by
light this is an experience unknown to
doors or windows the doorways through
which we gaze
suffer no distress by being flung open
besides if our eyes are equivalent to
doors then when the eyes are removed the
mind obviously ought to see things
better now that the doors are away
doorposts and all that's clearly not the
case or you know you have your your
sinuses burnt or something oh now you'll
smell better because there's nothing
getting in the way no we need both
sides the mind and the body working
together in order to have sensation
the last really interesting thing that
he's going to consider
besides the you know mind spirit being
born and dying
he's criticizing democritus and
democritus is somebody who
epicurus took a lot of his theory from
adding a very important contribution of
the swerve but he
essentially accepts democritus's atomic
theory lucretius says another
error to be avoided one sanctioned by
the revered authority of the great
democritus
is the belief that the limbs are knit
together by atoms of body and mind
arranged alternately first one
than the other you know so the
primordial the atoms are arranged
alternately singular primos
posita alternus
and the argument that lucretius is
providing here
it's hard to see exactly how it applies
he says that
in fact the atoms of spirit are not only
much smaller than those composing our
body and flesh they're correspondingly
fewer
in number and scattered sparsely through
our limbs
so he seems to be saying democritus
in the
reconstruction of how mind and body are
being put together
he's got the wrong the wrong model
instead
the atoms that are composing the mind
are very small there's less of them than
there is the body so it's not like just
laying things on top of each other
it's a different way of arranging these
in in relation to each other
the last uh thing that he talks about
that i would say is criticizing an error
and this actually covers a wide
range of things so we're going to talk
about this
separately in its its positive
presentation
is the idea that uh the
mind or spirit
is
immortal or doesn't die or that it you
know it was
born before the body and then waited to
get into the body and this is you know
attacking
plato and other people who think that
the
mind or spirit or soul whatever it's
going to be understood as
essentially predates and precedes the
material
body because it's a different sort of
thing
and lucretius is saying no no it's
material it's born with the body it dies
with the body it's not exactly the same
thing as the body but it is material
like the body and the mind and spirit
are essentially interfused
through the body with the mind the
rational part the anonymous being
located primarily
in the chest and then the ana ma the
rest of the vital spirit is throughout
the entire
body as well so these are the mistaken
points of view the errors that lucretius
thinks that many people fall into we
should say one last thing as well why is
it important from lucretius's
perspective to avoid
falling into these mistaken perspectives
it's not just so that you get the theory
right there is actually a practical
upshot to it
believing the wrong things about the
nature of our mind or spirit and its
relation to the body
therefore you know what we in fact are
as human beings and how we work
is going to lead you to
suffering
problems that you don't actually have to
have if you want to have a happy life
you need to get straight about how
things actually are and actually work
with the
mind the spirit and the
body
you